[Music]
a local non-profit has the goal of
keeping families together
and preventing homelessness and
encouraging self-sufficiency
to and of course a big part of that or
an organization that is
helping them out is findlay automotive
and tyler quarter
from defending automotive joins us today
to talk about
hope link of southern nevada tyler
thanks for joining us today
thanks kendall it's good to see you how
did you guys get involved with hopefully
you help out so many non-profits and are
associated with so many good things
how did you find them and and why did
you team up with them
well we i've known some people that are
associated with
with hope link and obviously with the
pandemic and all the
problems that has created hope link is
kind of at the forefront of
helping people that are are being are in
crisis because of the pandemic so
we we connected with them we supported
him a little bit financially
here in the last month or so but i
really want to tell
people about them because and the
services they provide so that
you know maybe someone listening or
watching will
could reach out and hopefully can help
them and sometimes the best way to
understand what they do
is individual stories and you have one
of those
yeah so we became aware through one of
our employees of a
a disabled lady a grandmother
and she has living with her her adult
autistic
grandson and they're losing their place
to live
through no fault of their own but
they're going to end up being homeless
and so
you know at shelters the shelters won't
take won't mix
male and female adults but this is a
family unit and it was really
uh we're having a hard time finding help
for them and hopelink stepped in and has
put a case manager on it and is
assisting them and getting them
set up and and the the really important
thing is
is that some of these people like this
in this case they don't even know how to
get resources they don't they don't know
how to
how to work through the system and find
out what assistance is available to them
or what benefits might be available to
them and that's what hopelink
is helping them do is trying to help
them find them a permanent place to live
and some solutions to help them in an
ongoing basis so that they're
self-sufficient and that's
that's what i love about hopefully yeah
and you know you know of course tyler we
have the greatest viewers
who do want to help out so if someone's
watching this and thinks hey i do want
to
help out hope link what should they do
well
uh so first of all their website is a
great resource which is linkedtohope.org
you can you can also find a lot of
information on their facebook page
um at link to hope nv or if you don't
have access to any of that just give
them a call at uh
70250
any of those ways to make contact with
them and hope link can uh
can get you set up with some assistance
all right and we'll have that
information on our website too in case
people didn't have a chance to jot it
down tyler
thank you as always for joining us we
want to thank findlay automotive group
for being one of our community pride
partners
rocky